Yeah, yeah, you're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than
itself. There's been a change in the image of thought, that's what it is, that's what it is.
The internal structure, as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth
it's divorced from the subject.
One, two, three.
Okay, now I have nothing to say.
It's just like the magic is lost, we had like incredibly pithy witticisms and
shooting back and forth at lightning speed, then we clap our hands like
it's like, uh, hi, how has your life been?
Yeah, well, it's like it's like starting the class, you know.
Yeah, it's like you you get the joke around at first and then once you start all the kids are
like their eyes just kind of go down like, oh, now we have to learn, yeah.
It's all about the same way, then it's all about
Yeah, well, the clap kind of sometimes that happens though, sometimes you have those like
whatever you happen to be talking about, you're like actually this feeds into the point that we
were going to discuss today, and there's usually a groan but it actually works because it's like
Yeah, you know, yeah, the clap is a little abrupt. It kills it, yeah, it's like, yeah, it's a hypo segue.
Mm-hmm. It is the worst segue imaginable. Imagine imagine if you had to do that in class.
All right, okay, time to begin everybody.
Great class.
That's a good place to start though in terms of a segue to the beginning of the excerpt just because like
it installs that very question of the sort of like the novel and the common senseness, the sort of
originary and the glossed over sort of derivative that just kind of begins, you know, the the project at the outset
like look here, you know, he kind of announces the project beginning we're interested in the question
of metaphor in philosophy, and you know, I think in many ways he's presuming that you know there is this
sort of natural division between the two and that when metaphor is used within philosophical discourse
that it needs to be tightly controlled by logic and that to think about like so this relationship is
particularly important if it's not controlled from a philosophical perspective, but then immediately he's
he sort of like jumps into this I've been, you know, I'm not familiar with this discourse, but it
it reads familiar to me if like I mean it it resonates with Niezsche on truth and lying with um
um Blake off and oh yeah yeah the Anatole of the Anatoly Anatoly France stuff from the garden of
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the um it's and it's in the form of a dialogue between um Poly Polyphylos and Aristos
right which the names are I mean are kind of they're important like Poly Polyphylos many wisdoms
against Aristos the best right so you kind of like this plurality against you know the more like the the so
anyway like the the moves of that dialogue are relatively familiar but I think have their own
flavor to them where it's like basically and Derrida says this is sort of a common move in the in the
18th century is that philosophical language technical language which presumes to sort of like get at the
stuff in itself is actually exactly the opposite it's always derived from a more sort of originary or
sensuous sensuous, um, sensory derived pr like proto language, you know, even like the very drive and
it's not shocking that like philology and etymology kind of like emerge out of this this era as well
to find the the true root or origin of of the word and you can think of like Herder and this in this
you know, um, milieu and as well as other I mean even Heidegger I think listening back to you know our last
season on Heidegger obviously much later but like there's this sort of words have this originary
sensuous power and then the more they traffic the more they get used within this sort of like economic
um uh uh this they have a certain kind of like linguistic cultural economy the more they sort of lose their
connection to that originary usage and the more they become abstracted conceptualized made philosophical
but there's always that root you can always sort of follow there's always a trace in that language
you can always follow it through back to its originary sensory sense um
and that like this becomes the sort of the the opening for Derrida's investigation and you know
you can tell like he's suspicious of this that there's going to be this sort of originary
place to track that you can neatly divide, you know, the philosophical discourse from this more sort of
and that's, and that's where the sun comes in
I mean, the this is foreshadowing, but the sun becomes the example par excellence of something
which is sensory but it's not simply sensory, right? It is a condition of possibility for all
you know, you can't look at the sun and yet it allows you to look at everything so it's like
it's not, it is and it isn't sensory and it's this primordial like that the notion of the sun is
already metaphorical it's already invested in a series of relations it's not just a noun that later has
relations but we'll get to that uh yeah yeah but it's also like when you read the sentence the
sentence that uh um it's Polyphilos attempts to activate, right? Like they return to the original
sentence and then his sort of translation of the sensory, I'm like what the fuck like that's it's so
bizarre you just wonder at that moment of like what what was the dude thinking like well that was
like how is this less abstract and I get it exactly more poetic it's sort of like more centrist but
like it feels incredibly abstract to me I mean just to read them out loud like basically Polyphilos
is is like look even in the most abstract philosophical languages let's take you know like
at random let's roll the die and find this super abstract sentence from I don't I don't even know who
this is the spirit possesses god isn't he extracts from a work which reviews all systems one by one
from the old Aliatics down to the latest Eclectics and it ends up with a sentence particularly abstract
and speculative the spirit possesses god in proportion as it participates in the absolute
so it's just that sentence this sentence the spirit possesses god in proportion as it participates
I thought that was Hegel but maybe I'm wrong I don't sound like Hegel it sounds like Hegel um
but it's it's which I don't think it is he doesn't he would have named it he would have named it is this
on the first page where are we this is 212 if you have if you have okay it's like on page one two three
five where it's like okay so through this process I can trace each of these abstract words it's like the
most abstract of all of the words are um uh uh like the the words of negation you know like absence
or absence like whatever like has some kind of negative connotation but you can trace them all
back to some kind of sensory origination and he takes each word and he does this and this is the sentence
that he comes up with because it's this is somehow more sensory primary the breath is seated on the
shining one in the bushel of the part it takes what is altogether loosed
he whose breath is a sign of life man that is will find a place in the divine fire source
and home of life and this place will be meted out to him according to the virtue that has been
given him of sending abroad this warm breath this little invisible soul across the free expanse
I took out the parenthetical sort of like asides in there but that's the sort of the one-to-one
correlation which is wild to me but still like also I'm sure quite meticulous and it's
and it's uh parsing out maybe maybe yeah so I mean it's just it's just weird to me to even
just to write the sentences I don't care what century we're talking about and to say
he used breath as a sign of life man that is will find a place in the divine fire source and home of life
and this place will be meted out to him according to the virtue that has been given him
uh of sending abroad this warm breath this little invisible soul across a free expanse it's weird to
me to say that that is more sensory yeah um than the spirit possesses god in proportion as it participates
in the absolute like yeah I guess it's more are those parentheticals in there are those um
uh polyphilosis asides or are those deridas asides do you think it looks like they're polyphiloses but
I assume it's Polyphilos yeah because I think if they were square bracketed it would be Derrida
but because they're just parentheticals I'm assuming they're at the
and he's being smart like by the by the humans I imagine there's a smart ass quality of course but
and so it's just the smart assery that I thought maybe it was Derrida but it rings a smacks of ancient
oriental mythology so I mean I think maybe that's also the issue is that reconnecting the sort of western
philosophical tradition to this mythological thing is as well that mythology is the more I guess bodily or
sensory um way of thinking of concepts so it's it's Polyphilos then who's kind of giving this
little critique of Hegel at the top of 212 then that is that hint that's his critique or is that
somebody else yeah okay so am I could I just is this is Derrida buying into this critique or he's just
Laying it out, he's just laying out as the condition of thinking this problem, right? I mean, yeah, it would
In some ways it seems like the edgy or sexier thing to say, like, hey, philosophy is founded on on metaphor.
Even to follow, like, the chain line, it's like what we call truth is sort of like sensory experience
sort of then abstracted and devoid of life and in, you know, like the language of white mythology is
Derrida's gloss on a line from Polyphibus, which is like what all the philosophy thinks that it's getting
away from, this sort of away from this sort of sensory uh language, but all it does is through it through a
sort of like strained and un sort of acknowledged process of metaphor um abstracts and covers over
this thing, and what it's covering over is just pure mythology, but it's a mythology devoid of sensory
experience, aka a an anemic philosophy, which then Derrida sort of renders as a white mythology.
Right, you know, right, and also the white man mythology of whack, yeah, yeah, yeah. White man is like anemic and
also racialized, yeah, white as the empty category that has no fullness, no character to. Right, well then
there is obviously still a critique of Hegel leveraged by Derrida in here then, right? It in terms of his
employment of universals and the negative, right? Like if we look back to from restricted to general economy,
you find those coordinates here towards the beginning as well where he's like, right, we don't want a loss
with an absolute return on investment; we want that general economy, right, is kind of what he's going for.
Right, so it's, well, I don't know, I mean just because the way he's setting up the problematic here he's
definitely setting up Polyphibus to like being too reductive, too simplistic in this, right? Because I mean a lot
of the move that I see here and and this is very interesting to me for rhetorical theory and
especially what sort of like dominated a lot of philosophy and rhetoric in the i mean, John, you would
know better this, but like the like the 90s I would say at least is a notion that there's a sort of a
primary rhetoricity to philosophy, like you know what Plato is doing, like all philosophical texts are rhetorical
not just in terms of their capacity, like their their orientation of persuasion, but on their sort of
like foundation of certain sort of metaphorics and tropes and and whatever else. And what Derrida seems to
be doing here is then like if that's a getting a rhetorical rhetoric getting under philosophy, Derrida is getting
under that sub-foundation and saying like don't presume that there's some kind of pure rhetoric that can
then found philosophical discourse because any rhetoric is going to put is going to produce presume a
philosophy and a conceptual network that is grounding the the rhetoricity or like if rhetoric grounds
philosophy, a prior philosophy is grounding rhetoric, and I don't think the point in that is to find which
one is really grounding which one, but is to constantly like is to point out the constant negotiations between
like these two forces working on each other. I I feel like the the bigger arena in which I saw this
kind of stuff and you still see it by the way like back when I actually was writing a book on style
a time that has apparently passed.
um This the kinds of projects that people would do about style and philosophy are exactly the kinds
of things he describes throughout the essay not just here at the beginning where it's like
take a text take Plato's texts and or whatever it is and look at the metaphors and figure out what is
the system of the metaphors that they do. There's a collection called Style and Theory in which people
do that with Derrida. I mean it's bizarre to me because you go like wait he's the guy that told you
the problems with that project, you know, or shows you the presumptions with that project but that's
that is often the way that people approach style questions is like let's look at or i mean you think
within the field of rhetoric I think the uh the arena that that was most clearly directed at was the sort of
rhetoric of science stuff which is let's look at the tropes and figures that exist in this allegedly
non-tropological discourse of of the sciences and so you're like Emily Martin sperm and the egg
right, like it's in really interesting stuff but it was all organized around identifying the metaphors
that are guiding the conceptual directions in thinking about you know biological phenomena, right? So I mean
that that that and even I mean, you know, even more broadly not just rhetoric stuff is I think a lot
of that is looking at arenas that we presume to be not metaphorical and showing that they are
metaphorical, like often Johnson, right, the sort of primordial rhetoricity or primordial metaphoricity
of of of all language, that all language is metaphor, but he's going after that notion of the primordial
metaphorical metaphoricity, like or he's attempting to problematize the ease with which that uh presumption
is made because it presumes again a kind of prior fundamental sensory from which the intelligible is
secondary derived and I mean this is and the word is Aufhebung, right? Like it is that that's where
Hegel comes into the picture is that metaphor is a kind of paradigmatic image of
exactly what they're relevé, you know, or um the Aufhebung move of Hegel is it's, you know, taking the
sensory and not canceling it, not erasing it, maintaining it, but surpassing it, and so that
both maintaining and surpassing thing that exists in the Aufhebung is exactly what we mean by metaphor
you know, or it's the movement of of metaphor. So I think in that sense
the whole notion of metaphor is underwritten or or one of the things that he's going after here is
the Hegelian logic of sublation. I think that you're absolutely right on that. He talks about
it kind of briefly. I mean, he he looks at Hegel's understanding of metaphor and also there's a great
footnote in that chunk on Heidegger where he's like this is exactly why Heidegger doesn't trust
metaphor. Like he does not like and won't use the concept of metaphor, although as Nathaniel points
out as we talk about his reactivation of the original senses of the words while not necessarily
a metaphor they seem to have a resonance with the kind of movement, you know, that that Hegel was
obviously interested in. So well because it's interesting to me like the different ways that
we can think of like the the different places in which metaphor functions because I mean but I don't
even I I really get to the point honestly for me I I do get to the point in reading this and this is it
starts here of course um but I get the point where I don't have any idea of what we're talking about
with metaphor anymore, like I don't have any idea like I just have no sense of and I get I get the
point that he's trying to make is not that there is a continuum and it's all the same and so my
reaction is not, you know, necessarily a helpful one, but I really very quickly like okay fine metaphor
means the sensory sensory transported to the uh to sense, right? Like to the until he immediately under
undoes that, right? Right, exactly. I mean it's and I'm like I don't even know and in this sense I mean
this is a commonplace: like all language is metaphorical. But what does that claim even mean? Like I don't
even understand what the force of that claim would be. Now I get again later sections where he's like
it problematizes the idea of the nominalizable, right? Like that that's the characteristic of
metaphor for certainly for Aristotle is that the the nominalizable and that that that you can name a
thing um and what he's going to show is that there is a kind of a constitutive again metaphoricity or
something movement that's already implicit in the noun, in the signified, in the meaning, right? Like so
it's not just a question of there's a meaning that you then transport to another place
right via metaphor from the sensory to to the imaginative, but that that original or primordial
meaning isn't original and primordial. It's already a product of relation. So I think charting out some
of the the binaries or oppositions that get installed in various ways and I think a lot of this comes down
to I mean one of the uh motifs that popped up over and over again for me was the the labor that is required
to install these various economies that you know like like various oppositions do work to install a
kind of schemata in order to think of you know this economy of metaphor versus that economy of metaphor
recommend yeah right now that it's the economy of metaphor that's right but is it that's an
interesting thing to me because even the discourses that are invested in saying for example look there's
metaphor in the sciences right? Like in other words it's trying to undermine this notion of a radical
distinction between you know the epist the language of the episteme and the language of metaphoricity
even those things start with the presumption of the distinction among spheres in order to recognize a
metaphor you have to say there are properly economic words there are properly you know what historical
words there are properly whatever like that these words have their original home and they're transported
into another arena so like even the effort to problematize or complicate you know the distinction
between spheres necessarily begins with the presumption of a distinction among spheres like it can't not
I mean it makes me think of the that problem that paradox of sense is that like in order to sort of
comment or take up a the sense of something what a new sense has to be installed that is necessarily
coming from a bit of a blind spot and that's kind of what happens with with metaphor in order to
examine a metaphor a new metaphor has to be installed from a perspective like in other words it's just
something to say like metaphors are always established from from perspectives and that perspective is its own
unidentifiable metaphor starting point which can then be taken up it's not an
originary starting point, it's not a foundation, but I think that it's establishing a handful of these
binaries is is valuable, like I mean, at least in the sure, it just just in terms of like the temporal
progression of them because the one he begins with is the sensory technical or physical metaphysical
distinction is that like yes, language has its primacy in sensory physical experience and then it becomes
meta, like through the process of metaphor becomes abstracted becomes metaphysical becomes technical
so that's that first binary that is installed, I mean there's a temporal by like binary temporal and bodily
like bodies have senses, language derives from that, and then a slow process, it's hard to tell where the
tipping point is, but they become increasingly nonsense, so there's that. you say it's that's that's what i
would call a materialist understanding. yes, right, like the the stuffness of stuff is primary and the
abstracted conceptual is secondary. yeah, so then but then he turns to someone, um
uh a reader of plato metaphor in plato, uh, and this is this is after the
paulie um philos and aristos stuff
and yeah this is on 2 19 through like 2 21 i think, um, so renee's uh work on plato's metaphors
he's like he establishes a different kind of or uses a different binary to establish a domain of
the metaphor, um, which is not this temporal historical materialist one by one focused on authorial intention is
like forget about you know, the distance from some kind of originary there is a meaning or an intention
of the text or of the author, and then the metaphor is a vehicle by which this is transmitted and so
like the logic of the metaphor is all internal to the sort of the network of ideas itself and this is how
you can derive it and then derrida's move is then to show another binary that has been installed and is
operating on this system of idea or meaning on the one hand and then language or communication on on the
other hand, and so this then becomes the operative binary and it becomes its own metaphor, right, like
like these these dichotomies are metaphorically installed and then there becomes the third one
which i kind of would have figured he would have started with, but the pro like because it's just so akin to
you know the most common definitions of metaphor, where it's just you know, a metaphor is just calling
using a word from one domain and then uh and then to to describe something in another domain, so using
you know, like in a kind of an improper usage, um cataclysis is sort of like the basis for all metaphor but
now we have another binary installed between sort of like the proper and the improper domains of something
like using a biological term to describe a non-biological feature, which as john you suggested
you have to have a relatively clear distinction of what counts as the biological and the non-biological
and that there are terms proper to it and there are terms improper to it, and so like it's but it's the
coordination and there's obviously a lot of overlap between them between you know sensory not or sensory abstract
uh proper improper domains and um intention um uh communication that are all sort of like coordinated
in within this the terrain of this problematic that this is what i mean when i last navigating those
uh when i last taught this uh prior to the this time around, um, it was when uh trump had just been elected
and was or was about to be whatever, right around that time and it was this whole build the border wall
thing and i was like this this is a whole discourse on immigration policy, right, like it's in terms of
the proper places that some someone is from and the the proper ways of allowing movement across borders
between spheres call it the economic and philosophical or whatever else, but that's that's it's the same question
like where is something from you're only metaphorically american, right, right, but really it's because that
that's the the whole question is is setting up this massive taxonomy of you know what's indigenous and
what's exogenous and what are the what are the ways of moving across the borders between fields that are
acceptable and in in acceptable means provide some kind of truth value in this case, right
um, and what are the ones that are unacceptable because they're cat because they're catacresis
right, like catacresis doesn't it doesn't generate anything in terms of the truth the truth value of the thing
um, and especially when you push the notion of metaphor a little further and you say like well
look metaphor is just saying this thing is this is that thing, um, which is all it's just the verb to
be, right, everything connected by the verb to be, which is where that one thing that says to be is the only
the only relevant verb. everything else is like to be running to be like eating to be like all those
things are secondary, it's the to be part and it's just saying this is this right, that all of that is
metaphor. so when i say a camel is a mammal, like i have engaged in metaphor the transport of something
into again species to you know class or whatever, regardless of, um, but that's all that that's all
that you're doing, and so in that sense every statement ends up being a metaphor, but only insofar as you
presume the pre-existence of distinct arenas and a proper home and, uh, a borrowed place, you know, so
it's like the necessity of having you have to have borders in order to have travel, right? right? but if
you say like just the the definition of difference if you say that it's just an endless process of
differentiation and deferral without the possibility of there being a stable meaning or origin, i mean that
just sort of gets at the Derridaian project as opposed to, you know, the fetishizing of the sensory, the
original sensory meaning or or in the case of the one that you brought up Nathaniel where the the
sort of reception of Plato where he's trying to take is that sort of a new criticism thing where
you try to take the text on its own terms without engaging like historical that's certainly
is that everything likes to do that? but yeah, new criticism definitely, but i think everything does
that like no no nothing wants to claim that they are importing their own taxonomies for understanding
they always want to say that they're letting the text speak on its own terms right right and
it's actually bullshit it's a total fucking like i i'm always every time i read that move i'm i just get
like i bristle with frustration and anger because like there is no own terms, you know? right? i mean
you're denying your own culpability in your reading of the text like that's if everything is interpretation
which Nietzsche says then there is no like valid sort of examination of a text right? there's no
there's no coherent system of the Platonic text that you can just identify and say like oh here's the
system of of words and metaphors and here's the true meaning i mean this is like that's like basic
rhetoric sort of right there like that you can't do that right like you can't make you can't you can
you know, but they are yeah yeah and you will making that right making that kind of claim is premised on
a series of questionable assumptions right it was sort of an easy takedown i feel like for Derrida in that
section of that guy who read Plato, you know? i feel like it was just like that he was just setting
him up and just like just got destroyed but it's a symptom of a type of reading that's what i was
saying like when i read a bunch of the style stuff like you just like almost everybody who looks at
the role of style or something like that it just says let's identify the figures and then there's a
whole structure for how you do that like where are the figures in Plato are they of a piece with
the thinking right like uh are they in other words are they important are they relevant metaphors are
they just sort of cast aside cataclysis, you know? i mean it's it's just a common place because when you
think about it it's sheerly on a practical level like a practical intellectual level but you just say
like okay i want to examine the metaphoricity of x's work like what are the ways that x tends to talk
about things well they tend to talk about it in these kinds of you know how else are you going to do it
right? like how else are you going to do it other than say i believe i know what a metaphor is
i believe i can recognize them and i can then classify them according to the various domains
from which they came and then the uses to which they're put and then i decide whether or not that
lines up with what i consider to be Plato's ontology or or epistemology or whatever we happen to be
caring about like those types of moves and that he sees in that in the one guy that he's reading is
like those are kind of the only moves you can make like they're and there are more or less subtle
versions of them that you see in contemporary thinking but they're all there so Genie vonstock's
analysis of figures in uh in the sciences which is totally interesting stuff works exactly like that
you know um and and there and plenty of people that do work following her and she's you know the rhetoric
one of the rhetoric of science who's like look at the metaphoricity of uh scientific texts and that's
how that's how it works like you have to presume that you know what a metaphor is what the original
the lending discourse is the borrowing discourse and the nature of the borrow to lend relation right like
yeah so i mean a lot of it has to do with like what's the value in pointing out the metaphoricity
of say scientific discourse is you know like one of them is to dislodge the authority that it has and
i think that's a valuable kind of thing the epistemic authority right the the sort of objectivist right
yeah yeah as in like i mean in other words like not to sort of like say you know the more dangerous
version of this which is i think we see the ramifications of this in the discourse on the right now
is that because it had a certain air of like a certain notion of its authority sort of uh damage
that now suddenly doesn't mean anything. Well, we can doesn't mean anything at all. There's no authority
it has no authority, has no weight, has no nothing. That's right, I was like, well, there's got to be
some distance between the purity of its authority and its complete non-value, um, but you know, the, I mean
I think, you know, the other thing to say is, and by the way, that's always a danger. I mean, that's one of the
things that I know like I kind of had that response sometimes when I read this and I'm clear that he's
not doing that but certainly lots of people have. It's one of the dangers of doing this kind of thing is
whether you're saying there's no difference between metaphors and concepts, between figures and concepts, like
isn't that what you're saying, that they're basically the same thing, that you homogenize and it just a
continuum of these things, and and that's not the claim that he's making, you know, it's that you don't
know in advance it is there's an inscription required in order to formulate the very distinctions between
these things is something different than saying there's no difference between these things. Yeah.
well i mean because i think a lot of the drive that he's trying i mean in so i didn't read him as
critiquing Pierre Louis the the plato guy so much. Well, I mean like obviously he doesn't agree with him
but i you know um i don't think he brought him up to to to knock him down. I i think largely he's
bringing him up to be able to showcase the different uh um logics that are being installed here and
the sort of the fluidity or the the the ease of of transformation between these various notions
of of metaphor and you know largely i think insofar as he's trying to critique something here is that
like look you can't create a stabilized terrain from which to advance your project. You can't say all
right even if even if you're provisional about it even if you are sort of like pragmatic about like
look i know i'm not sort of dealing with the truth but you know for the sake of let's imagine that you
know this is a metaphor intention is going to you know run the show and then now i'm just going to
do my project in here and at least tentatively speaking i know that that the parameters have been
set. I think even very saying that's like that's impossible and it's not even impossible it's not
desirable either that as soon as you start like you can absolutely launch implicitly explicitly you can
certainly activate a some like nature culture binary or whatever whatever it's not going to create a
stabilized space it is going to work on the thing that is working on and it's going to be worked on
by the thing that it is working on so you know there there is no stabilized space there's no stabilized like
the the binary itself is not stabilized and the object that is working on is not stabilized it's only
transformed now that's important that's worth following through but what it doesn't give you
is a distanced perspective from which to like to safeguard. Yeah, yeah, I mean I i yeah i do think
there's a critique of the Pierre Louis thing in there like it is he definitely there but i don't
think i don't think it's the point i don't think because i i Nate's right it would be too easy like
this is a symptom but the the this is a symptom, you know, like he proceeds in these ways but they're
not personally idiosyncratic like he he thinks that he can get to the organizing principles of plato's
thought via this approach but you can't right like and and what's required in order to do that as a
whole series as he says like there's a series of paradoxical uh propositions that are you know
it's the conception of metaphor that necessarily lends itself to the type of work that so it's not like
the guy made an error or aired it's that if you if you have this conception of metaphor which is by the
way the conception of metaphor it's not like there's another one uh if you have this conception of
metaphor then therefore you're going to do some variation of this theme you can't not so
but like you know these are simultaneously paradoxical and traditional propositions
um louis allegedly has opposed himself to the traditions of the things that he's just that he's just done
so i mean again to me it's always like it's it's a symptomatic reading i think of yeah here's a
here's given a way of thinking of metaphor which is the only way of thinking of metaphor there's
only a certain kind a certain series of things that you can do
and there's a whole morality to that right that's built into it i mean that's the obviously the
recurring refrain: like this is not a methodological procedure that one can you know take care of at
first but the whole presumption so it's like look he ends up being guided like his his notion of
metaphoricity ends up being guided not by the metaphors but what he believes to be plato's ideas
right like again we return to so the the whole interest in metaphorsity is to attend to the
Specificity of of the language of the figural, right? In other words, to get away from the privileging of
Plato's ideas and get to Plato's writing, and yet in order to do that thing at all you have to the whole
thing is organized around what one believes to be the important philosophical ideas of Plato, and it can't
not be, you know, so you're re-inscribing the very concept figure distinction that you undertook the
thing to to get rid of, right? Well, and there's all these presuppositions and presumptions loaded into
the methodology so that the the outcome, the product is prescribed sort of from the outset or it's prescribed
arbitrarily based on the interests and motivations of Pierre Louis or the author, right? So like, yeah.
I was just gonna say, I wonder, I mean, like, just talking about the presuppositions, which is what
like we've been talking a lot like, you know, in order to get something off the ground you have to be
able to presuppose a bunch of things, and like one of our favorite things is to point out, like, oh, here's
the air and presupposing that, and then the next move is to say, but you got to presuppose something, and
there's nothing unproblematic that you can presuppose, so it's like an unavoidable thing.
What if I mean just throwing it out there, like, what if we just didn't think about it or we thought about
it less as a presupposition as more of like the activation, intentional or not, the activation or
the the um the making work or the making labor of certain like virtual virtual dimensions, virtual
dimensions? Yeah, like it's not that like, you know, I accidentally presupposed a sort of like
gendered binary here. It's like, no, this thing gets activated, right, regardless of my intentions or
presuppositions because that's where there are particular pathways that connect the two.
And by the way, the second they get activated that gender binary is going to start operating on the
thing that I've, you know, inaugurated, and going to get operated on by the thing, and just as a way of
trying to destabilize the the general specific or the transcendental, uh, uh, sort of like practical
but that level, that level of critical awareness or reflection on the process of positing your own
presumptions, that's I feel like that's what Darrah does after and that's what he's saying is absent
from a lot of philosophical discourse is that they're just not maybe not sufficiently, it's not
the right word, but they're not like adequate adequately attentive to the how their text is produced
you know that's by their own thinking, you know? Yeah, no, I agree. So it's all, I mean, the you know the
thesis insofar as there's a thesis here is that it's all catacresis, right? Like they're just but
there are different styles of catacresis to get routinized or habituated as non-catacritic
right as metaphors, um, or and then as concepts, right? Like that, that's, but it's all catacresis, like
well or what's a what's a metaphor? It's it's a catacresis that I find valuable so you know
one man's metaphors another man's catacresis, right? Right, right, yeah. But even but even but take the
next step on that, even the question of value is organized around a metaphorical question of transfer
right? So even that. So it's not just that I happen to find valuable like it's already built into a
notion of value too. So all of the thing, the whole thing is catacritic, whatever. I think we need a TV
timeout on the the catacresis thing, just like, yeah, for those who aren't like don't have a lexicon of
rhetorical tropes. But catacresis is just the the misusage of a of a word, and so it can be often
you know it it can be often just sort of like you use the wording correctly or it's a mistake. Now it's
included in the figures, right? Instead of saying, instead of saying these conversations are interminable
you'd say these conversations are uh uh terminators. Yeah, there you go. Yes, like like and often it often
just sounds like you use just you just use the wrong word, you don't because you didn't know what you had
to bring for it, whatever, whatever. Now it's usually included in like in a list of tropes because it can
be artfully deployed as well, like it can like this mistakenness of it can be part of the rhetorical
artifice so catacresis is usually included in a list here and so like the reason that we bring up
catacresis is to say that like if a metaphor is the the the usage of a word outside of its proper domain
then in many ways that is just what catacresis is except except for that, you know, the metaphoric
usage is we can establish a a linkage perhaps an improper linkage but a linkage between them that
we find valuable. Yeah, but but again I I I'm going to insist on this point like the it's not just that
we happen to find valuable to what constitutes value that we find is also itself constituted by that
catacresis, so it's not it's it's not just like oh we like these ones it's like no no what liking
means, yeah, uh, and what we means are part of it too, so it's it's it's catacly values are produced
In other words, yeah, like values are are produced, yes, absolutely
Well, we saw, we solved that, yeah. I'm, I'm kind of, I mean, I don't know if you're going somewhere
specific Nathaniel, but obviously the Hegel thing is I'm just, I, I wonder because we he doesn't fully
treat the Hegelian discourse in in this text, but I'm wondering what his evaluation of Hegel's version
his style of philosophy would be in this context because I feel like in some ways he would be kind
of buying into the the polyphilos line where Hegel is using the negative almost deceptively in order to
provide the illusion of a consistency or coherence of of thought, right? So like there's this illusion
there's this facade of the one or or of unity in Hegel that's kind of mobilized through his language and all
of this is kind of like deceptive, fascist even in its in its impulse and drive, right? So like even just
his diction and the way the way the Hegelian sentence moves is all in service of this totalizing
uh principle where you want to be able to identify the ground, you know, of human being or of consciousness
or of history, etc. Um, but so that's exactly where I I don't find Derrida to like be in in bed with uh
polyphilos at all because that's exactly his project not to find it in within sort of like
the transcendental concepts but within sensory experience, that's the origin or the ground and
to me the like Derrida's turning to him to to show to complicate the the smuggled in philosophine
of like of of um the physical versus the metaphysicals like in order to buy that there is an
originary sensory ground from which philosophy is built as an impoverished version of that sensory
ground you have to by the way let's also say let's say a philosophical distinction yeah but let's
say simultaneously impoverished and grandiose, right? Like so it's it's in it's impoverished in the
sense of relative to the sensory but it elevates it. That's exactly the Hegel point, right? Like it also
elevates it simultaneously. Well, that's I think Derrida's claim in terms of the economic, like because
he wants to talk about in terms of usury which is like there is a loss for like a surplus. I is would
you say that's polyphilosis claim? Because I I had a sense that is clearly just negative, right like
yeah he's just like philosophy is bull. I mean for me I I I think that polyphilos is just saying
philosophy is bullshit because it's it's it's um, it's impoverished, um, uh, self-deceptive Oriental
mythology dressed up as as fancy talk. I think that's right. And so what what he fails to do is the second
the second part of the Hegelian move and to say it's precisely through that impoverishment that it
becomes generalizable and absolute, like that's how you get to those notions. So the the second
part of that that he gets I mean Hegel's right after that, right, on on 224 or whatever, um, where
that's what he gets from like Hegel is the one that will teach us, yes, that impoverishment and the wearing
away is also what creates the inestimal inestimable value, you know, it's it increases the value exponentially so
the usual which is the wearing away and the simultaneous what is the return on the investment
of the the loss of the money, the capacity to talk about anything at all because if we were only
dealing with sensory, like primary sensory experiences then literally nothing is exchangeable for anything
else. So if you want to have any kind but you'd have to yeah but you'd have to push on that and be like
I I get that I mean I I agree with you on one level but on the next level I go like what could be a
possibly purely sensory? Oh I don't think anything. There's nothing that would be purely sensory. I mean
that's where the sun comes in as this sort of uh but he wants to presume that like hey look, you know
philosophy has degraded this purely sensory, that's right, language, and then and so like my claim is is
that presume that a purely sensory language is possible. Like I don't think it is possible and
here's one reason is even if you just even if at the most fundamental level you could say like you know
thinking about Nietzsche's truth and lies, like imagine you could have some sound utterance that was
uniquely hooked to an experience, right, that like it didn't fit for anything else then all you you would
at most you could get a lexicon without any grammar, right, because you would never be able to because
every every sound utterance would be um totally like purely tethered to a a past moment it could never
be reused for anything else which means there would be no transmission, no communication, no repetition
this is the animal language right now which one this this is the animal stuff right like why this is
we're on the Aristotle section when we talk about this where where Aristotle says where he's talking
about the phone like the importance of the the phoneme and and why it's not a letter, you know, it's
like because it has the potential to be combined into a word which animals make sounds and they make
distinctive sounds but those sounds don't form words; they can't form words, so it's all organized around
this notion. I mean, everything about that is organized around the notion of the idea, yeah, you know, right.
Right, well, I mean, you get in Heidegger too, like, sort of the both with the fetishizing of the Greeks
and kind of the um centralizing of the animal consciousness too, like, where it's like because
they're not dwelling in mediation, they have a more immediate access to the will to power or whatever it
is, you know, and the the Greeks also, by extension, they weren't oversaturated in representation, right?
So they had some sort of more immediate existence, and that's enviable for for Heidegger, so it's like
we there there is that sense that we have to return to this place of immediacy and Dionysian sort of you
know, although I think that but but that's where to give Heidegger his due and why he doesn't like metaphors that
that that's not sensory, right? Like it's not simply that that return to the more originary is itself
an already a being with dwelling, uh, that is not not simply a question of like the sensory as distinct from
the intelligible. Yeah, that's right. I mean, I mean, in other words, like this is his sort of building on
as well, right? I mean, like that sort of yeah, like yeah, complexifying, you know, like there's not an
immediate, I mean, I think for Heidegger there's not an immediate sensory even possible, that it's all
no, no, but like but they're building, right? There is a sense that's why, but that's also sort of why
you wouldn't have something like a phenomenology for Heidegger, like, even though we pointed out a lot of
links, but there isn't first a sensory that then is transcended to something like to a higher and
sublated to a higher level, like it's not a series of stages, you know, even even interconnected stages
and dynamic stages, but there aren't stages. That's what I meant by bringing up herself. I don't know
my herself very well, but that is that is my sense of herself is that it's sort of like staged from the
sensory, like the phenomenal, like phenomenology stage from from the sensory to the conceptual to the
right, you know, right, to the world to spirit to the spirit. Yeah, I guess my sense of herself
I like, correct me if I'm wrong, but like my understanding of sort of like Heidegger's
departure from that is that the worlding you begin with welding, it's always being good with sense, yeah.
Yeah, I mean as a side note, I think Husserl's phenomenology is much more vulgar and that there's
the discrete domains, right? So, like, the sensory domain is in itself sensory, right? And then you move to
mediation, etc. Um, Hegel, I think, you know, as my little Hegel fanboy that I am, I think he's a little more
complex than that, but but I mean with Heidegger what but then how would you characterize his return
to the Greeks or his fascination with Greek life then? Would it be that the usher the user you sure
is like less saturated, like where it's like it's not an oversaturated use of representational language
at that moment in time, right? Where they're they're able to sort of live, um, how would you characterize
that? Like it depends why is that better, right? Like it depends on how how we read Heidegger, right? Because
there's and and he does he negotiates it more or less deftly in different places where he says
this isn't a question of it being overwritten and erased; that doesn't mean it was simply present for
them either, right? Like, I mean, so so there are places where he does say that kind of thing, so it kind of
depends on which Heidegger we look at, but yeah, the kind of the the big sort of caricature picture of
Heidegger that we've been mostly dealing with is that yeah, there's something at play in language uh that has
gotten covered over in the representational thinking of language that's prior to and the condition of
possibility for uh representation that one can still reactivate but not represent; that would be the
important part, right? Like, and why it would distinguish itself. It's not like we can get back to it and
adequately show it, you know, uh, because then I think it's own representational because the kind of
primacy that Heidegger is after is I don't think a sensory or embodied or material uh originality
but I I I think the primacy is more of I mean what is proper to design is to think its own being
and emphasis there I think maybe on thinking, um, and so like the the problem of both a uh originary
primitive sensory language and a highly abstracted, you know, technical language is the sort of the rigidity
with which the like um that's the signifier and sign are attached to each other, which then only
allows for like mechanistic relationships. It doesn't allow for the kind of ambiguity that is essential for
thinking that sounds yeah no yeah I mean I guess I was sort of using the the vulgarized version of Heidegger
where it's like just a fetishizing of the Greeks but obviously as we learned in our season on Heidegger
there's much more nuanced yeah take in places too yeah yeah in place like with the whole treatment of the
Overman, the Overman is not a return to the simplicity of the Greek life, you know. It's something totally
different. It's a transmutation. It's a change, um, certainly not in Hegelian Aufhebung, but yeah.
There's a complexity to that sort of ethical insistence on changing our way of relating. That's not simply
a let's get back to, you know, the homestead, let's get back to making fires kind of shit, you know, but but
that certainly gets taken up as one of the Heideggerian motifs if we could sort of simplify, right? And
get back to the natural, and so that's not, you know, it's certainly not unavailable in Heidegger. It's
quite available.
Heidegger is for the environmentalist types, yes, talking to you in a family reverse.
Well, no, I mean a lot of people like uh, you know, when whenever I know someone is a Heideggerian I
often think, well, and they do turn out to often be those like, hey, I like nature more than I like
you know, yeah, I'll take the phusis over nomos every time, but again, but that usage of Heidegger is it's a
limited, right? It's like, let's return to the richer expanse expansiveness of life that we have detached
from. I mean, that is not Heidegger is not always about that or he's not really about that at all in
some cases, you know, the whole like the post-humanist kind of uh, right, the the the point of departure for
a lot of post-humanism via Heidegger, right, that kind of vein of that research is Descartes, right? We
have to get away from the binaries of Descartes in order to return to what was before those binaries.
That's right, and Heidegger's whole take on that is that being is always withdrawn or is always withheld
from us. So even Descartes' mistake, right, in his opposition of body and mind, or you know, in his
whole presupposition of there being a transparent consciousness that contains a relevant truth for
Heidegger, yeah. And that's our withdrawal from being, right? That's a constitutive moment, you know, in in
that's where I mean I I agree with you. That's why I always think like the big Heidegger lesson
is the problematizing of being as presence. Yeah, right? Like now now you can certainly say one can
learn that in Hegel, right? Like, and I I will agree to that. It's just super explicit in Heidegger, like
being is not presence. And so there is no there there that you could just be like, ah, let's get back to
the originary sense of being. It's not it's not originary. So, but it's not until you get to
Derrida that you get the self-conscious complication of those distinctions, I think, right? Like the same
kinds of moves problematizing of being his presence, you know, yeah, but
is there a way of thinking in the passage of I mean we at one point said like none of us really
know how to talk about metaphor right now, and I understand the futility of trying, but
still like to be able to have always wrap my head around, I had and I had a little bit, I know, and I
have such an allergic reaction to the word metaphor now, like anytime someone comes and it's like, oh,
that's a metaphor, I always want to, and it's the Deleuzian in me that's like there are no metaphors
right? Like I just want to say like let's just take the hard line, like there are no metaphors when I
when I use, for instance, as I frequently do use viral metaphor, like we got to infect students, right?
We got to come up with ways of infecting the ways that they think, and they're like, oh yeah, that's
the metaphor. I'm like, no, no, no, it's actual infection because, right, infection does isn't owned by the
biological milieu and then being transported into a conceptual milieu. It is not owned by any place.
So it's an actual, and as much I think it's the same thing, but as much as you know, the virus infects
the thinking infects. Like, it's it is the same word, obviously, rather it's different, obviously different
mechanisms, but but that's when you're like, well, it's not the same word, right, in a different milieu, it's
that's again I'm back to the whole style question. It's always this rep this question of repetition
and difference, sameness and difference, like how do you locate that even provisionally? Yeah, I mean so
often when we talk about metaphor in the Nietzschean sense we always have to like be very careful and
say like this is not metaphor in in the traditional sense, like this is just like a it's a meta or it's a
metaphor of metaphorics. It's outside of its proper domain or whatever, right? But it just seems like
there's maybe a more um uh ready passage between those sense of those those commonplace senses of
metaphor and the chain sense of metaphor which is like if you start to erode the possibility of the
proper and improper place and you start thinking about like, you know, these are we literally infects
you know, like the like the conservatives were right in the you know, the 90s and like we are
infecting students with, you know, yes, like perhaps not intentionally certainly not programmatically or like
Top down like you know we're uploading them with ideas, but we're definitely, they're definitely getting
infected, right? Um, yeah, yeah. Then suddenly that sense of like that supposed non-metaphor, that that literalness
sounds a whole lot like the metaphor of interpretation, or the metaphor that that Nietzsche looks about
It's just pure appropriation, just one thing. This is why I keep on coming back to the labor or the
activity of something, one thing working on another thing. Yeah, yeah, you're gonna feast on this one
conceptuality is something other than itself. There's been a change in the image of thought. That's what
it is, that's what it is. The internal structure of, but as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth
it's divorced from the subject